l'albatros est prêt pour accueillir le
103e open de france de golf de
l'histoire la compétition est organisée
de ce jeudi 17 à ce dimanche 20 octobre
au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines une date
inhabituelle pour un événement programmé
ces dernières années fin juin mais cet
open automnale ne semble pas perturber
l'organisation où je serai pas aussi
positif si j'avais des doutes mais non
le staging la façon à laquelle ses
montées c'est très bien on a
l'impression datura un tournoi en tout
cas et le plateau de joueurs et pas mal
le plateau de joueurs sur un notamment
composé du danois thomasg en capitaines
de la ryder cup 2018 à saint quentin en
yvelines
les meilleurs golfeurs français sont
également présents sur le parcours de
l'albatros avec notamment victor perez
dernier français vainqueur sur
l'european tour
le joueur de 27 ans numéro un français
sera le chef de file de la délégation
aux mon objectif cette semaine forcément
de de performer au mieux d'essayer de le
prendre comme n'importe quelle semaine
même si forcément c'est difficile à
l'été en france
et voilà après c'est de nous concentrer
sur le jeu je connais le parcours ce qui
est un avantage
autre star de cette édition le parcours
avec les 18 trous de l'albatros comme
toutes les années devrait donner des
sueurs froides aux meilleurs il a
préparé juste comme il faut il et la
sélective mais il n'est rien et
franchement il est en super condition
bas c'est un des meilleurs parcours de
l'année donc après c'est dur de ne pas
être content l'atlant l'open de france
de golf se terminera ce dimanche soir
avec peut-être une victoire française la
première depuis 2011 et un certain
thomas levet